[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar solve every hereditary disorder
case for all types of genetic variation
i am kayleigh bach of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by kyogen to learn more visit
kaijen.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
georgios stamulis phd molecular
geneticist
digital insights director of global
product management for hereditary
diseases
dr stimulus you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much for the introduction
my name is giorgio stamulis uh i'm the
director of global product management
for hereditary diseases in gaijin
digital insights i'm extremely happy to
be here today with you
and i would like to thank everyone for
registering and attending our webinar
today uh i'll try to give you
a good overview of how someone can solve
every hearing disorder case for deep
different types of genetic variation
including cnps by using a qci interpret
platform
here is our agenda of our talk today and
i will start with a quick introduction
on the current landscape of their
disease testing
uh as the father of medicine hippocrates
uh had the theory of four humors
like the black bile the yellow bile
black and phlegm
which were detrimental in order to
assess the health or diseased status of
an individual
nowadays we have four nucleotides which
determine our health or disease status
and it's extremely important
to make sure that we can
decode any uh
genetic variation
uh in our genetic code with a proper
accurate and very fast interpretation
workflow in order to give answers to
complex hereditary disorder cases
the impact of hereditary disorders as
you may know already is
very big globally
more than seven million infants are born
each year with a serious birth defect
and approximately thirty percent thirty
percent of all infant deaths are due to
genetic disorders with more than seven
thousand uh genetic diseases
been known
and
which are which have individually
recognized
so
the impact is huge and
there is a big need of proper solutions
proper workflows in order someone
to properly
identify the genetic variation but then
also to assess
the impact of the genetic variation on
the phenotype of
each case
here in this uh
slide we can see the hereditary testing
field and it's evolution
with the evolution of the technology of
course
uh at the start of 2000 uh we had the
approach of single gene uh testing then
uh there was a trend
towards multi-gene hotspot
panel uh testing
then
the multi gene action panel with ngs
was broadly adopted
nowadays
we see more and more whole elections and
whole genomes
uh being sequenced and
starting to become the new trend for
heritage disease testing
and uh of course more
verticals of
data will come soon and will be combined
uh in order
to properly and more accurately assess
its clinical case by taking into account
different parameters different
measurements from
different data sets
this progression of technology is
extremely important and very helpful
for the hereditary disease testing but
also for the patients and their families
since
more patients and more families can get
answers to their
genomic riddle if you want
however this uh expansion of technology
this progression of technology comes
also apart from
big findings that we have a big
progression we have also big challenges
that we have to face in order to
accurately and properly assess different
clinical cases
in this slide you can see
that with the rise of next generation
era
we have also
the expansion of new findings and the
gene to phenotype relationships
that have been
extremely
big over the years
especially when ngs
arise
and you can see also indicatively at the
left bottom part of the slide
that last week in nomine we had
approximately 7
200 phenotypes for which the molecular
basis is known at the moment and the
total number of genes with phenotype
causing mutations
is more than 4500 genes at the moment
there is also
a big
need but also a very good progression
every day
in genomic research
and we know that approximately every day
one new gene
is identified and is associated with
different hero heritage ordered
phenotypes and it is estimated that the
number of genes which are involved in
the hereditary space
is around 9 000
genes
so with over 25 000 variants in a whole
action setting and more than 3 million
variants which someone can observe in a
whole genome setting the question that
arises is how can someone confidently
but also quickly and accurately analyze
and interpret variants from
an ngs test such as whole exomoral whole
genome
this is the big question that
everyone tries to answer and to
make sure that
have the proper tools in hand in order
to provide patients with accurate
and reliable diagnosis of hereditary
disorders
the three key challenges that clinical
labs uh are facing which are conducting
ngs testing and especially i would say
large panel ngs testing for hereditary
disorders
is first of all
the fast interpretation
everyone wants to have a fast
interpretation because this results
faster around time
and uh of course this is for the benefit
of the family and the patient
uh and as uh we know uh the
interpretation workflow is a is
challenging when it comes to larging
panels and the whole likes on the whole
genome because the amount of data that
someone has to assess
is huge there are many variants there
and someone needs to have all the proper
tools with the all the right evidences
in order to properly assess the
different genomic variations
that
occur after a whole exome or a whole
genome run
moreover
another challenge is that someone should
make sure that they have proper
annotation tools and solutions
uh which
are detrimental for an accurate
interpretation workflow at the end
but in order someone this
in order a lab to develop such
a solution
is very costly but also it takes a lot
of time and a lot of resources so
someone needs to make sure that they are
addressing this need by a proper
provider
with
an accurate and reliable tool
most importantly
it's extremely
extremely important i think to mention
here
uh that one of the biggest challenges in
the heritage space and especially
speaking about whole action and whole
genome testing
is uh all the knowledge and the
evidences that someone should take into
account in order to properly assess a
variant
and not only to take into account the
knowledge that exists out there but to
make sure that this knowledge is the
most up-to-date
evidences that
someone is using so the challenge here
is to stay current with the everyday
advancements of
the scientific field
so as i mentioned uh there are different
challenges that the fact that we all
agree is that indeed there is a trend
towards large panel approaches with a
transition to whole election whole
genome
the challenges apart from those three
that i mentioned before
is the fact that we have huge amount of
data and variants thousands and millions
to be assessed
is the need of a flexible but also
scalable interpretation workflow
is flexible that can be used by
different individuals in the lab the
director of the lab but also the variant
scientists
flexible in terms that
a workflow that can be integrated in a
lean system for example
but also
another challenge that someone may
face
is
the interpretation time as i mentioned
before which is critical for a faster
around time
of course bigger panels means bigger
interpretation effort
and there is an increased demand for new
evidences for this accurate
interpretation
the in order someone to keep up with the
most recent bibliography and latest
evidences should make sure that they
have the most reliable tool enhanced and
the proper training for that
and of course
last but not least someone should
mention that uh when
we have to deal with
uh hereditary disorders we all know that
there is many times high genetic and
phenotypic originating for specific
groups of diseases
and is
also another layer of difficulty there
in order to properly assess and
interpret the variants
in these cases
is of detrimental importance the
evidence is that someone is taking into
account
in order to properly
interpret uh the genomic data
uh the cnvs as well is one of the
biggest challenges on this field
uh regarding first of all the
the detection of cnvs and on a second
step as soon as someone has detected
this
the proper interpretation of cnp's with
the proper evidences but also
proper guidelines which are specific for
cnv's analysis
i will move now
to an introduction of our kaijun digital
intensive hygiene
clinical insights interpret platform
for uh
for the rest of my presentation when i
uh
when i speak about qci interpret i'm
referring to caution clinical insights
interpret
i will first try to give you a brief
overview of
digital insights
our team consists of hundreds of
scientists and engineers
but also other specialties who work
daily to keep on top of the new clinical
literature and to provide products that
help translate genomic data into
clinical insights or actionable insights
gaijin digital insight provides a
variety of products in different areas
from academic research
uh on human samples all the way to
clinical laboratory testing
and one of the fundamental and core
things we do is to curate these
evidences from the scientific literature
and to keep it up to date for you so you
can get a constant
current view of what's known to be
clinically relevant
and of course gain insights into your
data and clinical results
cajun digital insights is serving uh
more than 90 000 customers worldwide and
our clinical decision support tools have
been cited in over 35 000 publications
the particular product i will talk about
today uh
kaijen clinical insight interpret qci
interpret
for which we will
show how it can enable a reliable fast
and accurate interpretation of the whole
election whole genome has been used to
interpret over 2.5 million patient
samples to date
this knowledge base uh
is our core the kaijan knowledge base is
our foundation
and is
something that we are very proud of for
uh
ensuring an accurate and proper
interpretation work so to our customers
this knowledge base as i mentioned is
fundamental and core to our products for
a reliable and fast interpretation
process
and i would like to touch a little bit
here on our curation process
our curation is
sort of like a factory-like process in
high scale
we have hundreds of pg scientists
working on decoration systematically
through curation protocols and processes
that are rigorously rigorously tested
and defined
and that provides very high quality
computable evidences which then can be
used
to put the data that
you are getting from your ngs runs into
context of what's currently known about
the variants and the mutations detected
the evidences are created from a variety
of different sources
such as scientific literature
but also we create medical guidelines
and practice guidelines drug labels
clinical trials as well as as well as
molecular datasets uh with population
wide datasets regarding genomic
variation and
potential pathogenicity of the variants
so a wide variety of different content
sources that are clinically relevant is
curated daily and that is done
through
a distributed workforce of scientists
who are trained on the various protocols
we use
and read the literature or review
or other
resources and integrate it into
what we call the kaijin knowledge base
this then enables our various
applications including qci interpret to
compute and combine all these relevant
information related to the variant of
your interest and put it into biological
context for you
so over the past 20 years
we have curated more than 20 million
findings
in order to ensure that geneticists but
also scientists across the globe
are using the most up-to-date
information so they can provide accurate
reliable and fast interpretation of
genomic variants to their patients
affected by hereditary genetic disorders
as well as somatic cancer
here i would like to give you just a
small flavor regarding the content and
so an example of a variant in this gene
we can see that all the curated info
related to the variant is uh fully and
transparently tied back to the source
uh from which uh this uh
curated
in this case this is uh
an example what we call variant findings
from this particular article where you
could
know very transparently uh the various
details in terms of whether the mutation
is uh
is germline or has a germline context in
the article
or if there is a disease association
with the gene
the population that has been observed
this mutation if it's a
childhood population or adult population
and a
different variety wide variety of
details that when they are present or
captured in our uh generation process of
these evidences enabled us to map for
example uh this finding if it appears in
a sample in your run
uh and uh through a kyogen clinical
insights interpret to be matched to all
the different evidences and uh be used
uh for you from you excuse me uh for
your uh
report uh needs
so
kyogen clinical insight interpret
is a clinical decision support software
which accelerates via interpretation and
reporting of hereditary and just tests
at scale and leverages on charging
knowledge base in order to deliver
variant specific
but also scientific evidences in context
of phenotype
or the diagnosis
there are numerous filtering
approaches that someone can use
very user-friendly
interface
someone can use but also
through
api
someone can submit their vcf data which
i will show
to you in a bit
and transparently compute the different
uh classifications for the variants
and of course last but not least it
generates evidence-based reports with
full transparency on these evidences
which are manually
curated from our scientists
qci interpret is a platform which can be
used for any hereditary application you
may be using
starting from targeted gene panels
panels for inherited oral disorders
heritary cancer
carrier screening
up to whole excellent whole genome
but also someone can
make sure that
they can do single sample analysis but
also familial variant analysis with
uploading multiple
samples in the platform
if this is under the needs of the user
let's see a bit the typical process and
workflow
qci interpret offers a flexible and
scalable
evidence-based interpretation platform
as i mentioned before whether you use a
kyogen panel
or any vendor's chemistry qci interpret
supports all of them agnostically
the same also happens regarding the
secondary analysis part
kaijen digital insights offer product
for secondary analysis called clc
genomics workbench which has a very nice
integration with uci interpret
but also
and and which can work of course for any
uh exome or genome panel
but in case you are using any other
secondary analysis uh qci interpret uh
uh is very agnostic and will enable uh
for you all uh the workflow from the
start to the end
um
then uh
regarding uh the
the the part of uci interpret per se
which is the tertiary analysis part
uh
as you can see someone can upload
the data in a in a format of vcf in the
ui in a very user-friendly ui
or through api
and then someone can do
can follow the the different uh
filtration strategies
uh and of course the classification
uh the classification of different
variants different types of variation
including cnvs
and then to assess uh accurately uh the
pathogenicity of different variants to
interpret them properly and finally to
create
a report
uh
in different formats uh
again even in ui or through api
so let's see briefly what exactly is
cadge and clinical insights and track
interpret as mentioned is a web
delivered application where you can
upload your patient data
along with the metadata for each case uh
on on our ui on this very user-friendly
interface or through apis
and kisha interpret lets you investigate
in-depth instrumentation in the context
of the
current most up-to-date
evidences that keijin has created for
you
and through computational uh means we
are putting those mutations into
clinical context
for the most informed variant
interpretation workflow for you and your
patients
this is uh why we refer to qci interpret
as evidence-based clinical decision
support software which assist you in the
classification and reporting of
different invitations
independent of uh
which next generation chief conducting
platform you use or with secondary
analysis platform or tool you are using
um
then uh we are providing a comprehensive
annotation and literature
resources so it displays uh the
information about the variation
in terms of its relevance in different
hereditary related conditions
clinical cases reported and all the
relevant literature available for each
single variant
which has been manually and thoroughly
curated by more than 250 scientists
daily but is also augmented
and powered by
the augmented molecular intelligence
approach that we are using
it's very fast and automated so we apply
the acmg guidelines in an automatic way
to give you a draft report from
which then you can review and refine if
you see fit
to get your final report in a streamline
way and all those evidences are curated
and are available
to you and automatically match with the
mutations you detect so they can be
included on your report
we also provide the customized reporting
solutions as part of qci interpret
many of our customers uh use exclusion
derby to generate their final signed
reports
uh after customizing the reports uh
there's an integrated also mechanism so
you can identify which reports are ready
for sign out
which reports are under review stage
and
do the electronic signature
and
as i mentioned we provide
a wide variety of customizations in the
report
so you can have essentially the report
look any way you like
and we can help you
put the relevant content automatically
into the report template for your
test product
so what we provide with our curated
evidences is all the necessary and most
update information
for assessing the clinical significance
of variants
uh we assess uh
the clinical significance of uh
variation in the germline context using
the acng guidelines uh which puts every
variant in
the category from benign to pathogenic
and for somatic cancer virus we also
have the actionability aspect which
provides the turing system
for specific mutations and different
tumor types so you could know how
actionable
is for patient in terms of treatment or
prognostic significance
so again all this information we
constantly curate on a daily basis and
the knowledge base powers the ability
for us to apply algorithms
which use these guidelines as frameworks
to automatically provide an up-to-date
computed classification
in
both
in both
categories of diseases like germline or
somatic
for your variance detected the in in
your samples
and
of course very quickly to identify which
may be relevant for your reporting
purposes
i would like also to mention something
very important regarding ucl interpret
which is the
process
of cnv interpretation
we now
have uh content
very enhanced content
for uh proper and accurate cnv
interpretation based on
the acmg
cnv guidelines
with computed pathogenicity uh
classification
uh more than uh 60 000
uh
agmd uh and kyjen curated the cnv
literature references are available for
cnv
classification and interpretation
but also we provide links to external
cnv databases and nomad
cnv's frequencies
uh in order
someone to to to check
the similarity of
a cnv
event
across
what is already known and with
previously
reported cnv
pathogenic or benign cases
i will show you uh in a bit uh one of
these examples in our platform
so with this now
i will uh jump to the last part and i
think uh the most interesting part of
our
webinar
which is uh
the different clinical cases that we
will try to see together in a qci
interpret platform
the different cases that we will see
today first will be
a cnv case uh
solved
by taking into account evidence is
linked to the phenotype driven ranking
feature and the clinical validity
a compile the terrorist case in a whole
genome sequencing which was solved
extremely easily uh by just adding a few
phenotypes there and in a few clicks
someone can get the phenotype and report
directly
the
the mutations found
and at the end i will show you i'd give
you a quick overview on the capabilities
of carrier screening and 3 analysis as
well
with qci interpret something that you
should keep in mind is that
someone can ensure that they have a fast
accurate reliable interpretation for
hereditary disorders without the need of
spending hours
in terms of
huge
data sets
because with
within a matter of of a few minutes with
few clicks someone
can properly identify and spot
the relative variants for
the case under investigation
so let's move now
to the clinical cases
so let's see
here or the first case
in this screen now you can see the user
interface of the
kaijen clinical insight interpret
platform
on the upper part
you can see some
evidences
for
the variant that
is selected different details such as
the position of the variant the
effect on the protein level
population frequencies the genotype the
impact but also very importantly the
acmg classification of the variant on
the lower part of the screen we have
the list of variants
which someone
can investigate in different approaches
someone can add different filters for
example here we have a whole genome run
which as you can see started from more
than 3.5 million variants and by
applying different filters for example
in confidence of the variant the
frequency but also the
prediction of deleteriousness of a
variant
but also different other filters that
someone can add such as a the genetic
analysis like if this is shown in
homozygous or heterozygous
variants
or if someone can add the biological
context filters
some others may would like to add the
filters for example in the pre in the
deleteriousness of the variant uh
which have to do with the position of
the variant if it's close to
an action or in an intron
associated uh with gain or loss of
function and different other filters uh
one approach is by editing this uh
filtered
filtering cascade here
but also you have the option on the
right where
someone
can see different other filters that can
be applied and these have to do
also with how you can visualize your
variants in this variant table
this is the first page of
our platform the the platform consists
of basically three pages this is the
variant list page
we have the variant details page and the
review and the report page which i will
show you very briefly
so here
on this case
we have uh an individual yeah a girl
that is affected
by uh
potentially a genetic disorder and there
are
some clinical symptoms
that
geneticist pediatrician have observed
and they have uh
ordered a whole genome
analysis for this
girl
the the phenotypes that they observed
were related to uh disease of retina and
hearing loss so
uh as i mentioned before in calcium uh
clinical insights interpret someone can
very efficiently
give as an input the vcf file of course
that we already did here and then to get
us into different uh evidences regarding
the phenotype so here
someone can add different phenotypes
such as
this retina for example
and also the hearing loss
that has been observed in this little
girl
and if we apply that then
it is calculating it is taking into
account this
pathogenic symptoms if you want and then
if we yeah
get uh the result we see that uh this
list has been minimized to very few uh
of these
variants compared to
the thousands of irons that we had
before in the list
so we see that the patient symptoms is
the disease of retina and hearing loss
and we have now a list of variants with
two of them seem to be
pathogenic and likely pathogenic in
ush2a gene
uh
which is related to usher syndrome type
2a
uh we see that for this variant
i'm gonna click here
uh the the compute classification
here uh is pathogenic
let me go back to the variant
the computed classification is
pathogenic and if i click
here i can see all the different
evidences
which are triggering the different
criteria which is extremely useful for
someone to understand exactly
more details about the variant
moreover uh i see another variant which
is predicted as likely pathogenic which
is this variant
and we see here again the different
pathogenicity
criteria that are triggered
here very importantly someone should
know that we speak about a cnv
so it seems that we can have maybe a cnv
with
another
small alteration here
which both of them can give rise to a
phenotype which can explain
the phenotype of the patient
as you saw it was very easily
filtered by applying just
the phenotype of the patient
and uh if we look now in
the symptoms
we can very easily
see
that we have for us syndrome here
five findings and the clinical validity
that is provided by our target knowledge
base
it seems to be definitive the
relatedness seems to be definitive
between the
information we gave and
the gene
we see that there are different findings
from cleanvar in this case if someone
clicks here can get directly to the
cleanvar page and get more information
with the different submissions in
clinvar for this type of indication
let's go now to the varian details page
here in the various details page someone
can see the different details about this
specific variant the description we see
that this is a cnv
and then deletion of x1 6364
and there is also a tab with the
assessment and the cnv criteria you see
that there are different
criteria triggered specific acmg cmv
related criteria which are automatically
assessed
there are also different other details
about the variant the position
but also
information and gene links which can be
very helpful for the user in order to
further assess the variant without the
need to going back and forth
as you can see there is also a section
of laboratory observations and someone
if has seen again this variant is very
important to know that this is a variant
that has been previously seen
in the lab
moreover i would like to highlight here
uh this section which speaks about
previous assessment
we offer this possibility as well to our
users so if a variant has been
previously seen and assessed in the lab
this is uh
this this notification here is shown to
the user so the user can very easily
spot this variant and very easily uh
assess and report accordingly this
variant for cn visas i mentioned before
is extremely important to mention the
breadth but also the accuracy of the
information and evidences that we
provide in cash and clinical insights
here if we click in the bibliography we
can see that for this specific deletion
we have
a huge amount of information we have
many references found
and very specifically someone can filter
the different
evidences and
bibliographies available
regarding the clinical cases if someone
wants to just look in clinical cases or
population studies
or uh also to filter the the
publications that someone is
investigating based on
specific cnv criteria for example
to give
some specifications about the overlap of
the cmv that is under investigation with
known cmv events
something which is very important as
well is that we give context to every
single
evidence center
publication uh regarding the cnv match
and we see here that there is a
publication which has an exact match
with 100 similarity score of this cnv
this is extremely important information
when assessing a variant and
specifically a cnv because the user do
not need to go back and forth in the
literature and look for evidences
everything is in front of your screen
and you can very quickly assess the
variant
so someone now if wants to put this
variant into a report all has to do is
to
set to click here and set assessment
i will just type pathogenic
excuse me pathogenic cnv
cnv just
for our purposes here
and
i click ok
and now we can see that this variant
will go back to the variant list this
variant uh has been
taken a character of a reportable
variant as you can see here
and i can do the same
for uh this
variant here
and i can
look now again in the different uh
evidences for acng criteria this time
the different criteria that have been
triggered there are different details
varying details the effect on the
protein that is extremely useful many
people are uh
very interested to have this view here
and see the different mutations that
have been
reported
on this
region
and where the mutation of this sample
lies in
there is also a section with reported
clinical cases for this specific disease
and you can see with this monogram the
different heterozygous or uh homozygous
or different
cases for this specific variant someone
click here in counts and get the
relevant
uh bibliography for this specific uh
mutation which refers to uh the
different clinical cases of these this
variant
moreover there are clinical cases
reported from other laboratories as you
can see here we have the agm
session number as well which someone can
click and get
all the details with the relative the
relevant literature
uh agmd which is extremely uh useful and
a gold standard offered
with conjunction with qci interpret
for
an accurate interpretation of hereditary
and germline variants
moreover there is a very uh useful
tab someone can look at which is the
different frequencies in population we
can see that we have different uh
frequencies for different ethnic groups
from nomads from esp
as well and last we have also the
functional impact from different
resources and
and
prediction uh tools such as cad polyphen
shift mutation tester or gene splicer
max and scan philippi etc
all of them are extremely useful
information over the summer to make sure
that they are assessing properly the bar
so if we look now in the bibliography
we can again have the same filtering
approach on on the statements of
bibliographies
and
i would proceed to
add these as well as
assess
as pathogenic and then someone
if wants to go and report
this you should click here on the third
tab with the review and report
and then you will
go on the report page that we are having
here
i'm sorry it takes a little bit of time
so here we are
now here someone can assess uh and add
any comments we see the evidences for
pathogenicity everything is ready to go
to report for both variants you can add
comments as well if you want an overall
comment
like
pathogenic
for example
and then you go to preview report
and
here is the report that someone can get
for example for this case that we just
solved
you can customize this report completely
the two variants are shown here
the assessment the different
pathogenicity
criteria that have been triggered are
available and
other information as well can be
shared
in the uh
in the interpretation report
as
based on your needs basically
so and now
uh since we saw the first case i will
move
to uh the second case which is a case
which was a complex case and uh here i
would like to show you again how easy
someone can filter based on
the hydrogen knowledge base and how all
these data sets are uh linked between
each other and how someone can filter
phenotypes so here we have a case of a
girl which
has a
a
very severe case of
theosis and hypothyrosis
and you see that again these
this run is run with more than uh three
million variants is a whole genome run
and
someone can look in different ways in
this
case someone can look
and add the phenotype
phenotypes here
and
i think this is what will be wiser to do
here since we want to minimize the list
of variants
so if we are adding here
the different
phenotypes
like hypertrichosis
um
this order here if you want
disorder of here
or
abnormal morphology
abnormal
morphology of here are some of the
phenotypes
that have been reported for this
little girl
apathy horses
for example
it's or something like autosomal
recessive because
it is expected
to be
autosomal recessive
uh
hypotheticosis
hypertrophies here
so we apply the symptoms now
so here after
adding these uh phenotypes
now we can see that we have ended up
with just 84 variants and someone can
sort now these variants based on
different
parameters
for example
i will close it for now uh we can see
first that we have some uh classified as
pathogenic here or likely pathogenic and
then most of them are
uh
likely benign or variants of unknown
significance
and we can see here that we have some
phenotypes with the phenotype-driven
ranking approach
someone can
sort them
based
on different characteristics uh here the
suspicion for this girl is that it has
she has
a disease which may be
recessive
and so someone can look for homozygous
or competitors zygos variants
so let's see if we click there
then
we will minimize even further this
list and we can see that at the very top
of this screen now we have two variants
in a gene called sphinc5
uh related to
neither tone syndrome
so if we click here now let's see what's
the clinical validity evidence is we see
that the clinical validity is definitely
for this
we have uh
four findings which are related to the
disorder here
and
more findings as well for the different
phenotypes that we gave someone if
clicks here can gate can get directly
the evidences and
publications from different sources
publications but also from
databases that provide the different
phenotypes information
and
we have all these evidences in front of
our hands to use it but also to report
if we want
very easily these variants someone can
look also for homozygous
uh if if need be here you see that there
is uh potentially some variants
that can be interesting like the scarf 2
but
this is not related to the phenotype so
most probably is not related to the
disease that we are investigating
uh and then we have the variant uh
details uh if we click back the
compounds of their zygos with varying
details someone can go invariant details
and report again
these two sphinc
five variants again we have all the
different criteria of acng that someone
can adjust accordingly and then to set
properly the assessments uh the variant
details the laboratory observations that
we mentioned before how many times has
been seen before
uh the effect on the protein the
monogram with uh
the different uh clinical cases reported
regarding homozygous cases but also
component terazyco's cases but also the
different
publications that are referring to these
clinical cases submissions in clinvar
hdmd
and other sources and last
we have the different frequencies in the
population and the predicted functional
input so if someone wants now to create
a
[Music]
report for these two variants can very
easily create the report as i showed
before
we can see that this variant has been
previously assessed as pathogenic which
is extremely important to create a
faster interpretation and here is the
report for this
variant again we see
these two variants that we have
and they have been shown as a pathogen
with all the different evidences
available and the criteria that have
been triggered for each one of these
volumes
again by using the
phenotype driven ranking information in
this
case we were able
here to show
by adding just the phenotypes there this
automatically pops up directly when
someone
clicked in the compound heterozygous uh
or uh
almost like a state if someone is
looking for recessive diseases
so this was another case and now i will
try to to give you
a quick overview for the hereditary
carrier screening
workflow which is very similar to what i
showed you already but also to a trio
case analysis that we are having
um
here for uh the hereditary workflow i
would like
basically
for the carrier screening workflow
excuse me i would like basically to show
you uh the
the
the the report that is very important uh
and the workflow is again the same as
the single sample analysis i showed you
before
you have in your hands all the different
tools cnv tools the thing type driven
ranking that someone can add
and adjust accordingly you can filter
based on different
filters here but also to sort your
variants based on the novel sex-linked
or
heterozygous of course a state that
you're looking for carry screening here
and to keep different variants for your
analysis such as pathogenic or lightly
pathogenic
in order to report at the end
then in the variant details tab
here the information that we provide in
the career screening is the same
the
the breadth of information and
the
the content that we provide for expanded
career screening
uh is uh very very big and it covers uh
all the needs of at least the existing
guidelines in different countries so
even if some genes are not let's say
under the
uh wider red of the fully created
content we can do that for you
and uh if we see uh the the carrier
screening report let's say that we have
this uh
list here excuse me
and someone wants to report uh some
variants uh from here for the report
for reporting purposes one of them may
be the atp 7bg gene for wilson disease
which is a serious disease and we see
that the problem here is at pterozygous
for this recessive disease so if someone
reports that with the way i showed you
before
someone can get
this kind of report which can be of
course customized based on your needs
as an expanded carrier screening
report
with all the information of that about
the disease
and
the recessive mode of inheritance
but also we provide info about
statistics regarding the statistics of
the disease and the mutation itself as
you can see here we have also the
different evidences for pathogenicity
and context clinical context for the
variant which is related to the specific
disease and last we provide also some
statistics in different ethnic groups
regarding the carrier rate but also a
monogram which can help better
understand the modes of inheritance in a
set of some recessive way from the
patients
with
this
here i will switch very quickly now to
the tree analysis as you can see here we
have again in the same uh
platform
now a trio case analysis and uh
we have the three tabs variant list
variables review and report the
difference here is that we have another
column which is the controls and in this
case are the parents of this individual
this individual is a girl a little girl
who has uh who is affected by
arrhythmias
she is affected by arrhythmias
and has some heart problems
and
as you can see here i have already added
this
and that's why we have very few variants
uh here
uh and if i click on here i'm showing to
you all the variants not just the
variant based on the phenotype driven
ranking on arrhythmia if i click on the
phenotype driven ranking i will get just
66 variants
and as you can see there are these
variants here that we are looking at
but since we are speaking about uh
physical uh
days of familial analysis
someone would like yes
your audio got muffled there for a
second but it came back right as i said
something but it happened once before
earlier for just a second and i wanted
to make sure that we were able to
make sure that your audio wasn't getting
muffled like that so i'm not sure if uh
maybe your mic is being moved when
you're clicking something but uh there
was a little instance where it sounded
like it got a little bit muffled all
right i'm sorry
that's okay
all right so
let me go back okay
so i'm starting again from here perfect
yes thank you
so if we choose the phenotype driven
ranking we see that we have only 66
variants here
and since we are
talking now about
a clinical
case of familiar variant analysis
someone can sort let's sort this
by the variant findings for example
uh so we can see the findings here based
on the evidences that we have in our
platform
and
it will be very useful for someone to
look in a familiar
case
to look in the difference in the
different uh segregation
of
of the variant in the family but also
the mode of inheritance
so if we want for example to look here
in a
compounded terozygostate
then we will get a few variants which
can be easily assessed as you can see
the only pathogenic seems to be
a gene related to familiar breast cancer
which is unrelated to this phenotype of
course
so then we may be interesting to look in
homozygous variants
to see if there is something there again
there is
not much here
regarding pathogenic variants
and also to uh there to uh
to agree with the segregation in the
family
so by clicking on the novos we will be
able to see then the novel variants
which can explain
potentially the phenotype so we see that
we have a variant here which is relating
to
tumors which of course may be unrelated
to our phenotype
but we see a couple of variants here
this one and that one that are related
to arithmogenic right ventricular
cardiomyopathy so these
two variants may be
very too strong candidates which can
explain
the
pathogenicity for this phenotype of the
girl so if we click again in the details
and we see the bibliography of this
variant we see here again the acmg
criteria for the bibliography would have
all the relevant contexts which can be
filtered and keep only the clinical
cases
or
so only the variant specific references
only and we see that all of those are
related to this specific variant
we can see details
like exactly where is mentioned in the
in the paper
and all of these information extremely
useful and can be added of course to the
report
uh with this uh i'm sure we are all uh
can i understand how useful is the
kyogen knowledge base and the content
that we provide there uh with the
different parameters that are available
for the filtering of the whole genome or
whole exam run in order to someone
very easily end up and identify the
causative variant of a disease in just a
matter of a few clicks rather than
having to go back and forth in different
databases and literature
all the evidences are curated by karjan
for you uh and is powered by a team of
200 phd scientists that every day are
manually curating uh new evidences from
the literature and different databases
of course this is powered as well by the
augmented molecular intelligence
approach that we are
implementing in our
curating efforts
with this i will close here the
presentation for the demonstration of
the platform and i will switch to a
summary slide in order to conclude our
presentation today
so let's summarize our
today's presentation
as i mentioned qci interpret provides a
scalable standardized streamlined ngs
interpretation and important workflow
it can help you interpret all types of
genetic variation including synwiss with
the most up-to-date integrated evidences
curated by kaijan knowledge base
no need for you to spend time on finding
evidences which can support your
interpretation all the evidences are
there for you already pre-curated from
our scientists so this saves a
tremendous amount of time from your
interpretation workflow which means that
you can have a shorter turnaround time
for your patient but also to assess more
cases daily in your lab
moreover
cajun interpret provides a very
efficient varying filtering but also
a powerful phenotype driven ranking
approach where someone can use and in a
few clicks just identify the variant of
interest in order to solve complex
cases which may have also high genetic
heterogeneity
we also provide triage on action levels
in this with uci interpret automated
hmg cnv classification with full cnv
literature support this is extremely
important because again you don't need
to look for these evidences the
evidences are ready for you in front of
your screen
if someone can use qci interpret first
of all
for any
test if this is single sample analysis
or if it's familiar variant analysis but
also on an on a very agnostic way
independent of which sequencer is used
or which secondary analysis platform has
been used in order to create the vcf
file which can be taken as an input from
qci interpret
of course the report is customized based
on your needs and your lab needs
and
all of the above
can
summarize and can reassure you that you
can have at the end
a proper
scalable standardized streamlined
interpretation workflow which will
ultimately
help you to reduce your interpretation
time which result of course in reduced
turnaround time as i have mentioned many
times during this webinar
with this i would like to thank you very
very much for your approach for for your
attendance and uh
i would like also to
uh express uh
uh many thanks to uh
kylie for the introduction and
the organizing of
the webinar
and with this i'm more than happy to
answer any of your questions thank you
very much again
thank you dr simulus for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
all right let's get started our first
question is
can someone gain access to the content
of kaiogen knowledgebase for more
informed interpretations by integrating
this useful evidence in an existing
interpretation lab workflow
yeah thank you very much for for the
question
that's a very good question as i
mentioned before of course
different users have different needs
and different labs have of course
different needs uh the the way that i
presented these clinical cases today was
through our ui user-friendly ui
interface
but of course
access to this extremely valuable uh
knowledge base which can help you for
your interpretation is uh is possible
through apis as well
you can
call through api all these very useful
content use it and integrate it in your
interpretation workflow
and of course
report accordingly
the variants that you want
based on all these evidences that are
ready uh curated for you so the answer
is yes someone can have access on that
apart from the ui through api as well
great thank you another question we have
here asks how accurate is the curated
data and evidence provided in the kyogen
knowledge base compared to ai methods
all right now yeah that's a very good
question
um it is true that uh more and more we
are hearing about the ai ai is a very um
uh attractive uh
terminology nowadays
um
the the content of uh kyogen
something that uh we should make sure uh
it's clear
is that uh it not only ensures the
breadth of uh of information as
an ai content may do
but on top of that it ensures uh the
quality and the accuracy of uh of this
content
the content of charging knowledge base
is powered by artificial
augmented molecular intelligence
approach which is uh then also
meticulously
curated
human
by humans by phd scientists in order to
make sure that this huge amount of
information is very accurate without any
information that may be irrelevant to
the user
so
the the content of kaiju knowledge base
uh if someone wants to uh compare it
with
uh
an ai just approach
what i could uh definitely say is that
uh it has not only the breadth
of
of the ai but
it also has a higher accuracy since it
since uh the content is
on top of everything else manually
curated and that saves a tremendous
amount of time from the user
i hope this answers your question
right thank you and it looks like we
have time for one more question here and
this last one asks how up-to-date is the
content of qci interpret
that's a very good question
we are updating uh the content as i
mentioned before
daily in different aspects
this is uh
the content is manually created every
day for new evidences by our
scientists
and
by augmented processing basically from
the clinical research literature
supported by hundreds of curators which
can ensure the completeness and quality
updated as well on generally weekly
frequency on the product side to ensure
that variants
are interpreted in the context of the
most current
gene disease
clinical evidences
and
someone who will be working with uci
interpret
one of the things that we'll never have
to worry about
is uh
the update of the content because uh
this is one of the most important things
that characterize the character
knowledge based content
well thank you again dr stamulis for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor kaya jen for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone goodbye
you